بين صبايا وجلطه عوده مزدوجه للنجمه جني
اسبر وبين منه ولدنا ودكه العبيد بطوله
لفايز بن جريس وبين سر الباتع ودفعه لندن
ناهد او بين الازهر ودفعه لندن ناهد
السباعي منوره في رمضان وجميع ما سبق
ذكرهم ضيوف تفاعلكم الليله اهلا بكم
مسلسل صبايا دراما رمضانيه بطابع كوميدي
وبطوله نسائيه بيتكلم عن قصه فتيات
بيعيشوا في بيت واحد وبتصير معهم احداث
ومغامرات متنوعه المسلسل بيعكس حاله
اجتماعيه ومواقف يوميه ممكن اي احد في
الحياه يتعرض لها وهذه السنه بيشارك صبايا
بموسم السادس في السباق الرمضاني ومن بين
الصبايا اللي شاركوا في اجزاءه السته
الفنان السوريه جميع اسبر اللي كانت
موجوده من اول جزء في 2009 واستمرت
مشاركتها لعام 2013 واليوم بعد عشر سنوات
رجعنا نشوف جنيه اسبر في شخصيتها المعروفه
في المسلسل باسم ميديا او دادو
[موسيقى]
غنيه عن التعريف
فاجات اللي فاجات فيها جني محبيها ومتابعي
المسلسل هذه السنه هي مشاركه بنتها ساندي
في المسلسل في الجزء الخامس انتهى وميدي
عندها بنت واليوم بعد عشر سنوات بتشارك
ساندي بدور بنتها واللي بتكون مقيمه مع
ابوها في امريكا وبتيجي تعيش عند امها
وبتتعلم قوه الشخصيه وكثير من الامور من
امها والصبايا اللي معها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من ايدك بقى ركزي شوي فكري
غير صبايا سته بتطل علينا
اللي له اربع مواسم رمضانيه بطوله كل من
الفنان زهير النبواني وامل الدباس وكانت
جاني شاركت في الموسم الثاني كمان من
المسلسل اللي بيتكلم عن مواقف يوميه بتصير
من الاسره الواحده وبين الجيران
وتنضم الينا من اللاذقيه النجمه جني اسفر
اهلا فيك معنا يا جاني وكل عام وانت بالف
خير ومتالقه دائما
مساء الخير وكل عام وانتم بخير ورمضان
كريم على الجميع يا رب علينا وعليك يا رب
جنين يعني الواحد لما يفكر انه خلص يعني
كان في مرحله معينه وصبايا وحقق نجاح وكذا
ايش اللي اغراكي وانك ترجعي تعودي لهذا
العمل بعد كل هذه السنوات من التوقف
هلا بصراحه
لاول شي لاغاني انه الناس ضلت كل هالسنوات
اللي نحن انقطعنا في عن تصوير مسلسل صبايا
انه ضلك عم تتفرج بهذا المسلسل على هذا
المسلسل وكانه نحن صورناه هلا
فمسلسل يعني حتى الجيل الجديد كلهم
بيعرفوه لانه ضلو عم بيتفرجوا عليه بصراحه
في محطات كثيره
على اليوتيوب فشخصيه ميديا حتى بالجيل
الجديد يعني من جيل بنتي بيعرفوها لانه هم
كانوا عم يتفرجوا على مسلسل صبايا وفي
كثير ناس كان طالب بهذه الشخصيه
والصراحه اكثر من هيك انه انا بحس المسلسل
اللي شفوته كل هالقد اثرت بالناس بيحبوا
يشوفوا الناس انه يعترف شو شو ممكن يصير
بهالشخوص بعد هالمده الطويله يعني الناس
تشتاق شخصيات اللي بيحبوها بصراحه
ذكرتي بنتك هي مشاركه معك الان في المسلسل
هل هي بدايه يعني طريق حيكون في التمثيل
ولا مجرد كذا صدفه
لا لا ابدا مو يعني هلا بكير كتير على
موضوعنا ونحن نحط خطه للمستقبل بس انا
حكيت انه انا ما انه الولد يكون عنده
هوايات ويقوي شخصيته بالظهور قدام
الكاميرا او على المسرح انا كثير ما لانه
هذا الشيء اللي اول شخصيته انه يتعامل مع
الناس يقدر يحكي قدام الكاميرا
فبصراحه لانه ساندي اول ما خلقت ما كان
عمرها يعني شهر وشوي الوقت مثلت معي بمشهد
بمسلسل صبايا بالجزء الخامس وهي كان مشهد
فحبيتهم يعني انا بكره هذا الموضوع عليها
انه شو رايك بتمسلي هاي الشخصيه انه
بالمسلسل
تفاجات بكمل التفاؤل وقت اقترحت عليه هذا
الموضوع
وانا مبسوطه انه هي خالد هاي التجربه بكل
ثقه وحلو بيت يعني انه هي كاميرا كانت
يعني كتير طبيعيه يعني
مع الكاميرا يعني
بس اكيد كمان يعني انت ذكرتي انه العوده
الناس حابه تعرف ايش صارت في هذه الشخصيات
بس كثير ناس وصلتك حتى التعليقات انه
كانوا بيعترضوا
الان يعني خلينا نقول في مرحله عمريه
مختلفه عن وقت ما بدات المسلسل وما الى
ذلك فبيقولوا انه كان لازم مثلا تغيروا
الاسم من صبايا وما الى ذلك وحتى اعتقد
وصل الموضوع لدرجه التنمر في التعليقات
والله ليكي انا بقول انه المراه بتظل صبيه
طالما هي من جوا بتحس حالك صبيه هيدا اول
شيء وانا بحس حالي
صحيح انا اتفق معك هذه حكمه اليوم احنا
صبايا للابد
الحجر
بس العشرين عرفتي لانه معناه الحياه هي
اول شيء طبعا
هلا هو مسلسل الصبايا ونحن وقت حكينا
بموضوع انه يكون في جيل جديد من الصبايا
يعني للشباب العشرينات اللي اشتركوا معنا
مو معقول احنا نغير مسلسل بس لانه والله
نحن كبرنا بالعمر ما هو نحن عم نحكي عن
اجيال او عن جيل الجديد يعني
اذا اسم المسلسل صبايا فمو ضروري يعني
اللي يكون النجم الاول كنا بالعشرينات او
بال18 يعني اليوم الجزء السادس
في تلاقي في الاجيال
سته الصبايا يا جلي
جميل يا روحي طيب اذا يعني خليني برضو
اكون معك في هذا الموضوع انه يعني وصل
الموضوع في تعليقات للتنمر والكلام هذا
كله وفي تعليقات على موضوع العمر والشكل
والعمليات وما الى ذلك انت ما شاء الله
عليك جني ما بتخافي تردي يعني في كثير
فنانين على السوشيال ميديا بطنشه انت
بتردي وبتردي لهدوء ردود لاذعه ليش
لا حبيبتي هي الفكره انه مو انه انا بسرد
بصراحه ليكي وقت بوصل موضوع لموضوع التنمر
وموضوع انه نحن بدنا
ننزع نهاره لهذه الممثل او نحنا بدنا نثبت
انه
سيء او كممثل مثلا انه بس انه نتمسخر او
بدافع الحقد فاكيد انا برد يعني اليوم
انا بس انا كمان انسانه يعني اليوم انا
وقت بيتنمر حدا على
عرضي بتنمر حدا على شكلي بتنمر حدا على
بنتي اكيد انا بدي رد وانا بدي رد
اليوم صح عندك مشاكل ممكن يعني الشيء هذا
يزيد من همومك او ما الى ذلك بس خليني بس
اقول في عندك انت وحده قالت لك انه دكتورك
يبدو هو نفس دكتور هيفاء وهبي علقت على
صوره لك في انستقرام انت رديتي عليها
وقلتي لها جربي نفس الدكتور شوفي اذا
بتطلعي تشبهينا يعني يعني كانك في كل
الاحوال بتقولي يعني ايش انه انا وهيفاء
وهبي اذا حلوين واحنا بنروح عند دكاتره
فنحن لانه الاساس حلو يعني
هلا هي بصراحه لانك انه ان كانت النجمه
هيفاء وهبي ولا كتير
موضوع التجميل
اي شخص واي صبيه نحن نلاقي بيكون عمر 20
سنه عم تعمل تجميل لانه اليوم
الشيء اليوم طبيعي بتلاقي انه نشوف الصبيه
اللي ما بتهتم بحالها طالما موجود
اساسا هلا انا مع التجميل شخص يكون بوعي
وعنده شيء هو مزعوج منه انه
بس انه انا كفنانه انه كل شوي لاقي تعليق
وتنمر على موضوع التجميل ولو كل الناس
العاديه سترات البيوت اللي هي ما بتطلع
الشاشه واللي ما هي الناس اللي بيشوفوها
كل وقتهم تعمل تجميل فليش فليش انتم عم
تتنمروا على ممثله وفنانه هي لازم تكون
دائما
بالموت الازياء وبالشكل
طيب بدي احط لك صوره بما انك انت مرتاحه
مع الموضوع وعندك صراحه جدا في هذا
الموضوع وفي التغيرات الشكل والعمليات في
صوره لك من الاجزاء المختلفه من صبايا اذا
نشوفها الان الان لما تشوفي حالك جني
بتشوفي حالك احلى بتقولي والله لا كانت في
مرحله ثانيه احلى هل عندك اي ندم على اي
شيء
هلا الصراحه مو قصه احلى يمكن بهذيك
الفتره والحقيقه كان البال مرتاح اكثر كنا
بوضع كان كنا ببلد كتير
منيحه وكتير مبسوطين يعني حياه مختلفه
بصراحه نفسيا انا بقول لك ايه انا كتير
متغيره يعني اكيد الازمات اللي مرقنا فيها
خلال عشر سنين اكيد هي اثرت فينا هلا
موضوع طبيعي الانسان يتغير وطبيع الموضه
تتغير في ناس بتشوفني قبل احلا في ناس
بتشوفني هلا ممكن على الموضه اكثر لانه
هلا صار بيختلف يعني بسبب هاي الحلوه وقت
انا بكون مرتاحه من جوا بصراحه اكيد هديك
الفكره
اذا بدي اسالك عن الاعمال المشتركه ليش ما
بنشوف جني اسبر في الاعمال المشتركه هل هي
مثلا عليها حرب معينه هل هي مظلومه دراميا
مثلا
في الاعمال المشتركه اغلبها موجوده
[موسيقى]
بالشركات اللي عم تطلع على القنوات
المشاهده كتير هي الشركات نحن بنعرفها
شركه صباح شركه
مشتغله كثير مع شركات تانيه يعني السنه
الماضيه انا عملت
اسمه بيوت من ورا انعرضت على محطه او منصه
مشفره يعني كان في نجوم من سوريا وكانت
النجوم من لبنان ومن مصر يعني عمل كثير
عملت مسلسل مشترك خليجي سوري المصري اللي
اسمها الريح كمان انعرضت على
يمكن ما كتير الناس يعني شافتها يعني او
محطاته مشفره مسلسل
جلطه اللي هو مسلسل مشترك اردني سوري يعني
بس مثل ما قلت لك في يعني شركات معينه
ممكن انا للاسف طبعا اكيد بتمنى اشتغل
معها بس ما صار فرصه اني اشتغل معهم فيمكن
مشان هيك العالم ما شافتني بهذا العمر بس
ان شاء الله لقدام
حبيت اليوم الكلام معاك لانه صراحه عندك
شفافيه وراحه مع نفسك جميله جدا يعني يا
ريت كلنا تكون عندنا هذه الراحه وفعلا
كلنا صبايا في اي عمر ما نخلي احد لازم
ياثر علينا نشكرك كانت معنا من اللاذقيه
النجمه الجاني اسبر شكرا لك
ايش في 2022 فاز الفنان السعودي فايز
بجائزه افضل فنان ساعد عن فئه المسلسلات
بعد دوره في المسلسل الشهير رشاش اليوم
النجم الصاعد بيصعد اكثر ما شاء الله وفي
رمضان وقبل وفي رمضان وقبل يعني في رمضان
هذا بطل وكمان قبل رمضان بطل ايضا ففايز
لسه تبيض مثل دور بندر فيه من هو ولدنا
اثنين والمسلسل هذا مكسر الدنيا بخفه دمه
وقربه من المشاهد
ابوي كان عندك كلام كثير وقصص واجب امي زي
ما هي امك لا
بعيده يا
[موسيقى]
ولدنا
المنصات في عمل اخر مؤخرا كمان لفايز
مخليه متصدر الساحه وقبل الموسم الرمضاني
شارك فيه بطوله تحديد المسلسل دكه العبيد
بشخصيه ذيب المسلسل من كتابه وتاليف هبه
مشاري حماده وبتدور قصته في اطار اجتماعي
تشويقي ببدايه القرن العشرين وبيتكلم عن
خمس قصص مؤثره لشخصيات مختلفه باماكن
متعدده مثل الهند وافريقيا واوروبا
الشرقيه والجزيره العربيه وحقق نجاح كبير
ونسب مشاهدات عاليه
عمك
معانا يا فارس
متعلق هذا الرمضان ما شاء الله
يا مرحبا ومسهلا بالشيخه ساره اهلا وسهلا
الله يخليك تسلم بتحتاج
[موسيقى]
البردوسكم
الجميع شيوخ يا مرحبا فيكم كلكم والله
شكرا لك فايز خليني ابتدي من اللي قبل
رمضان يمكن لانه دقه العبيد كان عمل مختلف
تماما تماما تماما تماما احنا متعودين من
هبه مشاري حماده على اعمال خلينا نقول
فيها جدل فيها تعدد في القصص فيها تعدد في
الادوار وتداخل كيف دخل او كيف بدات معاهم
في هذا المشروع
جدا جدا صعب بس الحمد لله التعب منسي لما
تشوف رده فعل الجمهور واعجابهم بالعمل
تنسى
ورده الفعل كانت واضحه يعني الناس عبروا
عن اعجابهم يعني بالمسلسل وحيكون فيه طبعا
انتم بتشتغلوا الان حاليا على الجزء
الثاني صحيح صحيح
بعض الناس قالوا العمل جريء او خادش
للحياه تحسيت هذا الشيء
يعني
بس لما تجيب قصه واقعيه لازم تجيب جميع
الاطراف اللي تتكلم عن القصه واقعيه ما
تخرج حاجه عشان تكون واقعيه انت ما تبغى
واقعيه انا قاعد
كصانع محتوى او كصنع فيلم او مسلسل احنا
نجيب
مثلا اخدش للحياه زي ما بعد الناس اتهموا
او كده
والله كل واحد له رايه خاص
ونظره الخاصه
وكل واحد يتفق انه مثلا انا اتفق انه خارج
الحياه ايه رايك الشخصي في ناس تشوفها غير
حادث في الحياه راي شخصي بس انا اقول لك
هذا مسلسل واقعي فلازم اطلق الواقع اللي
فيه عشان انت كمشاهد صدقني هو على العموم
اصلا كان في جدل يعني على حتى مواقع
التواصل يعني على هذا الموضوع خليني انقلك
على من هو ولدنا يعني نجاح الجزء الاول
خلاكم تعملوا الجزء الثاني كيف وجدت الجزء
الثاني
طبعا
انا مستمتع جدا من ولدنا الجزء الاول
والثاني بوجود المخرج جميل
بوجود الكاتب الجميل بوجود المنتج الجميل
وجميع طاقم عمل كممثلين
نتمنى ان شاء الله هو الان قاعدين عروض
فيه اختلافات الاراء بس انا اقول لمسلسل
في بدايه حاليا ومتاكد باذن الله خلال
الحلقات الجايه راح يعجبهم كثير لانه الان
الان في الحلقات هذه بدت الحرب بين ريان
وبندر فراح تصير اشياء باذن الله انه
الناس كانوا جالسين بيتكلموا وبيقولوا لا
الجزء الاول احلى
صحيح في في ناس كتير تقول الجزء الاول
احلى بس ما نقدر نقول الا لما ينتج الجزء
الثاني لانه بالجزء الاول فبداياته
ما تحكم على العمل لننتهي طب فايز ايش
ابرز عيوب ابراهيم الحجاج
والله ابو حجاج بالنسبه لي انا انا ما
اقدر اذكر عيوبه لا لا انا ما ابغى محاسن
ما ابغى مديح ابغى عيوب
ما امدح هو عارف
اقسم بالله انه انسان رائع وجميل سواء على
الصعيد الشخصي ولا الصعيد التمثيل يعني
مره مره على حبه بعيدا عن الاخوه انا
اتكلم الان كواحد متابع
بالنسبه لي هو واحد من افضل الكوميديين
حاليا بالسعوديه اذا ما كان افضل تبين
مدحته انا كنت حابه كذا يعني اني نعمل له
حركات كذا وننتقده يعني اعرف نزعلك عشان
اقدر اخش ههه
ما سمعت اقول قولي مقلبه عشان اقدر مقلب
مقلبك
كذا
المديح طيب خلاص ايش نسوي نمشيها له هو
وحبوب بصراحه يعني بس ايش نسوي طيب انت ان
شاء الله كمان عندك مسلسل كمان نازل اللي
هو عربستان برضو انتاج ضخم ايضا
صحيح
انتاج عربستان بالنسبه لي عمل مختلف تماما
على اللي سويته وبالنسبه لظهورك عرب ستاند
راح يكون مفاجئ لكن هو مبني على كتاب شهير
وناجح يعني جدا قصه روايه
اسامه المسلم المعروف ما يعرف الجميل كان
في ثلاث مخرجين العمل جدا جدا جدا ضخم من
اضخم الاعمال اللي ممكن شارك فيها الفتره
اللي فاتت
مخيف اتمنى باذن الله يكون ناجح والمتوقع
باذن يكون ناجح ان شاء الله
سابقا الناس تستغرب انه هذا فايز عشان
اشياء كثيره صارت في العمل والشكل لا هو
اصلا ادوارك في الفتره الاخيره يعني فايز
مره مختلفه عن بعد صراحه يعني انت بتحرص
انك انت تعمل اختلافات فيها طيب خليني
اقول لك على موضوع ثاني فايز تلاحظ انت
يعني انه اغلب يعني متابعينك او المعجبين
فيك صح
الحمد لله بارك الله
طيب انا
طب يعني ليش تعتقد كده ماشي الموضوع مع
المعجبات يعني هي بركه من الله اول حاجه
كل مشاهد او كل متابع له نظره الخاصه
تابعوني سواء عشان التمثيل سواء عشان
اللي اقدمه بشكل عام الحمد لله
يعني انا ما احب اذكر شكلي من جهه
التمثيلات ولا بشكل عام احاول اني اجيب
شخصيه تخلي الناس تقول اوكي هو معلش
الكلمه قعدت
ابدا اظهر بشكل هذا احب اظهر بس احاول
دحين الان في مسلسلات كثير ناجحه اللي هي
دايما كده بتقوم على قصه علاقه انه حب وما
ادري ايش وكذا ما حاولوا انه يعملوا لك في
هذا المنحه يعني والله يعني في في اشياء
تقدمت لي بس انا قاعد احاول اتجنبها لانه
ما ودي اخش في الطريق هذا لاني بعلق
بالطريق هذا والناس بتشوفني بالطريق هذا
انا ما بشكل كبير للدراما والاكشن بشكل
مره كبير وبتعمق باذن الله بالدراما بشكل
عام ان شاء الله طيب في اسئله كثيره على
موضوع انه هل انت خاطب هل انت متزوج هل
بتعيش قصه حب كل هذه التفاصيل تحب توضح اي
منها والله مبدئيا ماني مخاطب ولا متزوج
حاليا
من زمان ذكرت هذا لانهم قالوا انه فايز
متزوج انا شخص متزوج ولا خاطب حاليا
والثالثه تتحفظ عليها
طبعا
طيب على فرحك يعني يا فايز
باذن الله نقول ان شاء الله خلص انا اول
الحاضرين ان شاء الله
الله يخليك فايز طبعا احنا دائما بنتمنى
لك كل التوفيق وكل الخير وان شاء الله
يعني انا عارفه انك انت بتصور كمان في هذه
الايام فالله يعينك كمان شكرا لك نورتنا
كان معنا الفنان فايز شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
بتاخذ الفنانه ناهد السباعي السباق
الرمضاني في عملين الاول مسلسل الاشهر
اللي بيتكلم عن شاب اسمه يوسف بيقوم بدور
الفنان عمرو سعد وبيتهم
فبيغير اسمه بيصير الاجهر وناهد بسرعه في
المسلسل دور جميله اخت الازهر
اما العمل الثاني اللي بتطل في ناهد في
رمضان فهو مسلسل دفعه لندن اللي بيتكلم عن
مجموعه شباب وشابات في المراحل او في
المرحله الجامعيه من مختلف الجنسيات ناهد
في المسلسل بالطل بشخصيات زينب وتنضم
الينا الفنانه ناهد السباعي اهلا فيك
معانا يا ناهد وكل عام وانت بالف خير يا
رب ان شاء الله
كل سنه وانتم طيبين وميرسي على المقدمه
لطيفه دي لا ما شاء الله يعني المقدمه هذه
بسيطه في حقك يا ناهد انت ما شاء الله
مبدعه والفتره الاخيره مبدعه اكثر واكثر
يعني كمان خلينا نتكلم عن الاجهر يعني
كمان الاجر ضارب على كذا مستوى بيطلع
الترند اكثر من مره احكي لنا عن هذه
التجربه ودورك فيها
دوري فيها دور جميله وهي اخت الاجار اللي
بيدور على اخواتي ومن الحلقه الاولى علشان
ياخد حق مامته
بيرجع لان هم تاهوا عنهم ان هو صغير
جميله بتبقى مرتبطه باخوها عماد واخوها
هاشم اللي هو الاخ المتعب مدمن اللي بيعمل
لهم مشاكل بس هما بيحبوه
وهي وعماد مرتبطين شويه ببعض وبتشوفي بقى
رحلتهم لحد ما بنشوف هيوصلوا امتى يعني او
مش هيوصلوا للاكبر يعني كيف التجربه معه
او تجربه العمل مع عمرو سعد
والله انا بحبه جدا من قبل ما اتعامل معي
انا بحب تمثيله قوي قوي وكان نفسي اشتغل
معه ولما اشتغلت معاه حبيته اكتر لان انا
لقيت فيه حاجات كتير جدا عمرو مش بس
بيفكر كممثل لا بيفكر كمخرج كملف وكمنتج
يعني هو دائما بيبقى عنده
وده اللي مخليه واصل للمكان اللي هو فيها
ان هو مش بس
شغله طبعا هو اهم اكتر حاجه مهتم بها وبس
في نفس الوقت كل الممثلين اللي حواليه
ادوارهم مهمه جدا وادوارهم مؤثره جدا
وهو بيبقى مهتم بده جدا وده ده ده حلو مش
بتلاقيه كتير يعني ناهد انت واحده من
الفنانات صراحه اللي كل ما اشوفك في دور
احس كانه انت فعلا في هذا الدور يعني احس
كانك ما بتمثلي صراحه يعني يعني هل يعني
هذا يعني كانك بتتقمصي
بتعيشيه يعني من جدد الكلام اللي بنسمعه
انه الفنان خلاص بيدخل في الشخصيه وبيصير
بعيش هذه الشخصيه في كل شيء في حياته وكده
ولا الكلام ده مبالغه لانه بقول لك صراحه
شكرا والله ميرسي قوي على كلامي الجميل ده
هو هو الفكره انه انت تبقي
مذاكره كويس بشكل معين بالطريقه اللي
اتعودتي عليها اول درستي بتخليك تبقي
عايشه في في المود عامه انا لقيت انه
احنا يعني معظم التصوير كان
[موسيقى]
ايام مكثفه
ومنعزلين بنصور ما بنصورش في مصر
فده بيخليك تركزي اوي اوي اوي لانه ما
عندكيش حاجه تعمليها في حياتك غير الشغل
فبيبقى في تركيز عالي جدا انا اتبسطت
بصراحه وده يعني لو انا لو انا قدمت
الشخصيه بالشكل اللي انتم شايفينه ده كويس
الحمد لله يعني فضلا من ربنا كبير
وحقيقي عمري ما كنت هشتغل كده الا لو كنت
بشتغل مع مخرجين كبار
واستاذ ياسر سامي واستاذ بكير يعني حقيقي
مخرجين كبار جدا ساعدوني كثير بس انت
الدرس التمثيل نهج يعني احنا كلنا طبعا
المعروف لا يعرف اسرتك يعني خلاص غنيه عن
التعريف ما يحتاج نقول الاسماء اصلا يعني
بس انت دارسه التمثيل ولا موهبه بالفطره
لا هو بصي انا دايما بشوف ان الموهبه ده
جزء ربنا بيديه لك انت لازم تشتغلي عليه
علشان تنرميه ممكن يبقى حد عنده ودنه
موسيقيه عارف يعزم اغنيه من غير ما يبقى
درس موسيقى بس هو عمره ما هيبقى
مايسترو او او متفوق جدا في المزيكا لو
درسها كذلك التمثيل كذلك اي حاجه ثانيه
فيها نوع من انواع الفن ممكن حد يبقى
بيعرف يرسم بس لازم يدرس رسم كويس قوي
عشان ينمي مهارات
فانا
كده انت بس تشتغل على موهبتك هو ده اللي
تعلموه الحقيقيه انك تشتغل عليها قوي فانا
ما اشتغلتش عن الموهبه بتاعه لغايه دلوقتي
ممكن جدا ما تبقاش ما تتطورش مع الزمن او
مع مع مع الحاجات الجديده اللي بنلاقيها
في كل حته حوالينا لازم تبقي دائما
الابتدائيه في كل حاجه شغلي معلومات طبعا
يعني بحاول ما اقدر واحنا شفناكي يعني او
بنشوفك في هذا رمضان في تجربه مختلفه كمان
تماما يعني دفعه لندن يعني دور مختلف
تماما دخلتي عالمسلسلات يعني هو يعتبر
مسلسل خليجي يعني وضارب جدا في الخليج
يعني
في الخليج دي حاجه حلوه قوي مكسره الدنيا
هو في الخليج يعني الحمد لله والله ده كان
اهم حاجه بالنسبه لي انا كنت عامله انا
يعني
المسلسل الاساسي او دوري الاساسي في
الازهر وكنت جست بس في دفعه لندن وكنت
مبسوطه قوي بمشاركتي معهم قضيه
وحسيت انه انا كنت دوري دور البنت المصريه
الوحيده فده في حد ذاته عجبني حسيت ان
الناس
القائمين على المشروع
صحيح وقت لما كنتم بتصوروا في الاستوديو
سمعت ثلاث مرات اوف بس انت الحمد لله ما
كان في احد موجود لا انا ما كنتش موجوده
الحمد لله بس هو الملابس واللبس ده كله في
لبس كثير قوي يتحرق وبضاع وحاجات كتير قوي
يعني
لا كان ثلاث مرات تتحرق الفتوحه غريبه جدا
كانت غريبه يعني كان في شكوك انه مثلا كان
شكوك انه بفعل فاعل مثلا او لا لا
يمكن سوء حظ ولا احد ضربكم عيني ممكن هي
عين هي عين طب وكمان واحده من الاشياء
اللي لافته يعني في شخصيتك عموما انك
جريئه جريئه انت ما بيفرق عندك وهذا الشيء
بينعكس على اختياراتك في الادوار ما بيفرق
عندك انت بتاخذي اي تحدي وفي نفس الوقت
حتى في تصريحاتك انت صريحه برضه ما بتخافي
انه تصريحاتك ممكن تزعل زملائك يعني مثلا
لما تقولي انا ما اشتغل مع المخرج محمد
سامي اذا زوجته مي عمر موجوده في العمل
محمد رمضان مش نمبر وان وطبعا يعني
حلو حلو خلينا الامور
قوي من الناس اللي بتاخد الاخبار بشكل
مختلف كويس ان انت الكلام انت في الموضوع
ده عشان اتكلم فيه صح انا بقول وانا
المشاكل انا شفت ناس كتير حصل لها مشاكل
لما
اشتغل وكان يعني زملاء وحصل لهم مشاكل
كتير فانا بحب ان انا ما يبقاش ابعد عن
المشاكل في شغلي انا انا هاديه جدا وعمري
ما حد سمع عني مشكله وعمري ما حصل ما بيني
وما بين اي مخرج او اي حد زميل مشكله فانا
مش حابه ان انا اعيد مشكله كان زمايلي
فيها واخدها ثاني يعني كان في ناس كثير
قوي طلعت عندهم مشاكل صح كلنا عارفينهم
انا مش مش حابه هو هو صح هذا الكلام ايوه
بس يمكن تجربتك مثلا تكون مختلفه يعني انا
بقى ايه اخاف انا ما بحبش ان انا كده انا
اتسالت انت تشتغلي في حاجه كده فقلت لا
طيب انا وانا احب جدا اشتغل معهم الاثنين
على فكره يعني احب جدا عمل يجمعني مع
استاذ محمد سامي واحب كمان ان انا اشتغل
مع مي عمر في يوم من الايام بس يعني يعني
كل واحد لوحده
كل واحد على حده طيب فهمتك طيب ومحمد
رمضان
ابو محمد رمضان
انا بقى في الفكره في الموضوع ده بصي هقول
لك على حاجه انا بحس انه
طبيعه شغلنا احنا فنانين احنا بنعمل صح
ده ما فيهوش نمبرز ما فيهوش تقييمات رقميه
ده احسن حاجه لانك بتعملي اقعد بتعملي
انا ممكن حاجه تعجبني وتعجبتنيش ممكن حاجه
تعجبك ما تعجبنيش صح ده طبيعي بس احنا ما
بنعملش عمليه حسابيه ولا احنا بنعمل
عمليه جراحيه يعني ما فيهاش حاجه احسن
كل النجم واللي يجي جمهور وكل اللي يجي
الجمهور وليه التيست بتاعه في الحاجه
وصلت فكرتك انا بشكرك جدا ناهد على وقتك
اليوم معانا نورتينا صراحه وكل النجاح لك
في المستقبل انت نجمه رائعه كانت معنى
الفنانه ناهد السباعي شكرا لك
مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام الحلقه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]